LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to "Coffee with a Googler."
Today I'm chatting
with Jen Person, who
has been the face of Cloud
Functions for Firebase
for some time.
JEN PERSON: Hey, how's it
going, Firebase developers?
Install the Google
Cloud Storage module.
Name is its path in storage.
I'll log the event
and then return.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Jen's here
today to talk about this
and also a couple of
nice big announcements
that she has for us.
Welcome, Jen.
JEN PERSON: Thanks.
Happy to be here, Laurence.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
you've been working
Cloud Functions for Firebase.
Can you tell us all about it?
JEN PERSON: Sure.
So I have made some content
around Cloud Functions
for Firebase.
It runs serverless
in the back end.
And so that enables
you to run code
that you wouldn't
necessarily want your client
to have access to.
And prior to working on
Cloud Functions for Firebase,
I hadn't worked with that
kind of trigger before.
And I really loved that
it was so easy to learn.
So at first, I was like,
I thought, you know,
a lot of this is stuff that
I could do myself already.
An IOS developer.
I could do a lot of
this from the client.
But then I realized
that it was definitely
worthwhile to learn Cloud
Functions for Firebase,
even though I wasn't that
familiar with JavaScript
before now.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And one of
the magic things of Firebase
when we first launched,
it was like all this stuff
that you can do in the
client without having all
of these tiers and
managing these tiers,
like for simple things
like data reads and writes.
But we've learned over
time that, of course,
people still need to have
code running on the back end.
JEN PERSON: Yes.
That's true.
We still need some things
running on the back end.
But Firebase is still taking
a lot of that work out of it
for us.
So it scales up and
down the service for you
so you don't have to worry
about managing that yourself.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And you don't have
to worry about managing
specific servers, right?
JEN PERSON: Right.
Exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
FTP to this one
to deploy code and FTP to
that one to deploy code,
like in the bad old days.
You just push it into the
Firebase and it does the rest.
JEN PERSON: It just works.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
now Functions works off
a concept called triggers.
Can you tell us a little bit
about that and what you think?
JEN PERSON: Sure.
So a lot of times you're going
to run some code in response
to something that happened,
probably client-side,
or it could be something
like a write to the database
or adding something to storage,
authenticating a new user,
maybe some sort of
important analytics
event, or maybe HTTP or Pub/Sub.
Something that normally
happens in your app and you
want to run some snippet
of code every time.
The code is triggered
based on that event.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And that
was a perception change
that I had to make.
And I didn't get
functions at first.
And I watched some
of your videos,
and then suddenly it
just dawned on me that--
because to me, like, back-end
code would always be,
I have to make a call, and
it would execute something.
And I might have a Cron job
that does it occasionally,
or it's just something
to respond to users.
But now it's like a field
in the database changes,
and the code will execute.
Or an off-event happens
and code will execute.
JEN PERSON: Right.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
It's really cool.
JEN PERSON: Yeah.
And there are a lot of
great samples of this
on our GitHub Function Samples.
And it's great to check it
out and try it for yourself,
because if you're not
sure what it can do,
there are a lot of options
out there to try out.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
there's a code lab as well
for the friendly chats,
and some functions
have been added to that.
Have you seen them?
JEN PERSON: Yeah,
actually, and it also
uses machine learning as well.
So you can really see
how Cloud Functions works
with all sorts of
other code that you'd
want to use in your apps.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
There's one really
neat function in there
that like-- because friendly
chats for a chat room.
And then sometimes people upload
bad pictures to chat rooms.
And so what it does is
it uses a cloud function
to call our cloud services
to see if this content is
objectionable.
And then if it is,
it blurs the image.
JEN PERSON: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's really--
that's one of my favorites.
Whenever I demo, I
like to show that one.
I show them the
blurred image and ask
them to guess what it is.
You'll have to watch some of
the videos to see for yourself.
So Cloud Functions, you've been
doing a fabulous job on this.
JEN PERSON: Thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And you weren't even
a full-time Googler
when you were doing it.
JEN PERSON: Guilty.
Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I hope this doesn't
seen too much of an
empty compliment,
but I was really
surprised when I found out
that you'd become a
Googler, because I
thought you were one all along.
JEN PERSON: Thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Which is great.
JEN PERSON: Yeah, I
had been a vendor.
So working for
third-party at Google
for a little over a year.
And actually, this is my second
day working as a Googler.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Always the joke
when somebody is on
their second day of job
is like, you came back.
So how's it been?
How's the second full
day of work been?
JEN PERSON: It feels great.
You know, it's such a
welcoming community anyway.
I always felt like
I belonged as well.
So in a lot of ways, it
feels like business as usual.
But it's nice to have the title.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's good
that you mentioned community,
because you're going to
be doing some community
work in the coming months,
right, some conferences you're
speaking at.
JEN PERSON: Yes.
I'm going to a couple
of conferences soon.
I'm going to Google Developer
Days Europe, which is
going to be in Krakow, Poland.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
JEN PERSON: I'm going to be
doing a talk on app growth
and app quality.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
JEN PERSON: And yeah, I'd
love people to check it out.
Showing some cool
Firebase features.
It's got a great story.
And I'm especially interested in
seeing other female developers
come out.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
JEN PERSON: I'd love to
communicate with them
and see what they're working on.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sure.
It's been a tough time for women
recently in Silicon Valley.
So it's great to have women
up front speaking and women
talking about cutting-edge
stuff the way that you have.
So if you're watching this video
and you're a woman in tech,
please, please come
along to our conferences.
You're very, very welcome.
And we'd just be delighted
to have you there.
And when we have folks like
Jennifer up front speaking,
hopefully it's--
she's been an inspiration
to many of us here
and hopefully she
will be to you too.
So as well as the
Poland one, you're
also going to be speaking
at the Firebase Summit.
JEN PERSON: I am going to
be speaking at the Firebase
Summit.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Can you give
us a hint on what it will be?
JEN PERSON: It's
definitely a favorite talk.
People really enjoy it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: No spoilers?
JEN PERSON: No spoilers.
LAURENCE MORONEY: This is
like "Game of Thrones."
OK.
So this is going to be
end of October, right?
JEN PERSON: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So you're going to be there.
The whole Firebase team
is going to be there.
JEN PERSON: All of us
are going to be there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: We're
going to do a bunch of talks.
I'm not allowed to talk
about my talk either yet,
but we'll be there answering
questions on stage.
And the whole thing's going
to be on video as well,
which is great.
So thanks very much,
Jennifer, for coming.
Thanks for being on this show.
JEN PERSON: Thanks
for having me.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I
know it's day two,
and you're supposed to be
doing your orientation,
but we dragged you out
to put you in the studio.
So we appreciate that.
So thank you so much for
watching this episode
of "Coffee with a Googler."
And if you've any
questions for me
or if you've any
questions for Jennifer,
just please leave them
in the comments below.
I would love to see you at
our events, particularly
the two that are coming up.
But you're always welcome
at any Google event.
Thanks so much.
It's going to be fun in Poland.
JEN PERSON: I can't wait.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I
wish I could be there.
JEN PERSON: Next time.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Lots of great food.